[Music]  so what can I help you with g  I'm not content  I get angry  that's the sort of thing you help people  with right yes  my whole life I have been trying to  figure myself out so I can help other  people understand themselves so they can  have good relationships and here I am  time to get back into therapy  I want you I want the expert I'm not  normal  I need to get better anyone who's come  this far who has made the choice to come  to therapy and keep hammering away at  the hard things  they can be helped  but I have got bigger problems  I have a compulsion  to kill people  should I tell you more about my life  successful therapy requires a safe  environment without anything like fear  hanging over every session  FX is the patient you don't mind eating  while we talk do you  streaming August 30th only on Hulu